[Music]
you
wait a minute where's the crawl and the
Star Wars title and the big music well
it's a different kind of Star Wars movie
but you see this isn't part of the
trilogy's that span three generations
this is more of a spin-off film it's a
story that stands on its own but also
happens to be in the same universe hence
the title world one a Star Wars story
okay Chris why the hell you talking like
that
like what like I'm somehow in front of
you even though I'm clearly to your left
that's just the Chris Duncan tradition I
always address the camera with my edited
thoughts it's kind of the Chris Stockman
way yeah well how about the Star Wars
way and we have an opening crawl I told
you Critic it's not that kind of movie
rogue one is the first of what is
currently an unending series of Star
Wars universe films while the trilogy's
will continue to follow the stories of
the characters we know and love from the
first movie these will be more
background stories think of them as the
appendix and the Lord of the Rings a way
to get more history of fictional events
and characters there's standalone films
that give us more information on a world
we can't get enough of so the idea of
cutting out the crawl is just a way to
show it's one of the many side stories
that's yet to come we had a theme a Star
Wars solstice this is totally get ruined
next year when we do a Star Wars feast
day of Our Lady of Guadalupe look this
is just what Star Wars is now it can't
be any worse than the changes they made
in the past no this is my show and I
want to crawl
I'm sorry
Bromley making letters float through
space if you can think of a better way
to make letters flow through space then
I'd like to see it I guess we're stuck
here for a bit Hey look okay while we're
waiting for the crawl to get fixed I
guess we should go ahead and start the
review you got it start that this is Row
one so a young brunette girl with a
British accent is separated from her
family and she spends most of her life
with no direction trying to cope with
that tragic day actually that was raised
character from 4cyl oh yeah how did I
get those two mixed up so a young
brunette girl with a British accent is
separated from her family and she spends
most of her life with no direction
trying to cope with that tragic day now
the store risk doesn't have a lot of
repeat but don't you think that's a
little cut and paste oh I'm sorry
I guess the young American guys didn't
get enough attention okay fair enough
after cheerfully accompanying the Rebel
Alliance chin has taken to their
headquarters where one of the rebels
named casseon reveals that her father
Galen is the architect of a new weapon
called the Death Star the man who raised
your name saw his name is Oh trust me I
figured all these names from some movies
over a secret information from your
father we're hoping you can infiltrate
him to figure out what he needs but I
didn't want to but I guess I have no
choice now how long did it take to say
all that less than a minute I guess so
why does it take us less than a minute
and the movie a dozen minutes to say the
same thing this movie goes beyond taking
its time it stretches out so much info
for a story that we already kind of have
figured out it's like watching it in
slo-mo yet they somehow talk in normal
speech some of it
doesn't even add up like when this pilot
named rook wants to defect for the
rebellion yet saw doesn't trust him so
they hook him up to a lie detector squid
the squid it's it's your feelings what's
your thoughts okay how does he do that
I don't know where did you find it I
don't know why does he want to help you
out I don't know what do you do if I'm
lying or not lying I don't know what do
you know I really that's gross
legs it also doesn't help that this
movie jumps all over the place
it seems like every other minute it cuts
to a new planet or solar system I've
taken you to rebel headquarters I'm
taking you to find Saul I'm taking you
out to wash that's right lunch it's like
they're trying to make a simple story
seem bigger by constantly trying to seem
angry and busy ah the George Costanza
method basically thankfully their team
is full of people who distract from that
like k2s Oh was kind of like c-3po if
they sucked out all the pussy nuts
greetings and salutations i MC Oh piss
off you pansy sup my big black rod
there's also a freedom fighter named
Bayes whose philosophy is shoot first to
ask questions and whatever this world
calls hell actually I think it's just
hell so this universe has both angels
and hell yet no Christianity keep in the
middle Orion Church and then of course
there's the blind warrior named yeah I'm
just calling it tough
but the downside is well many of them
are entertaining we don't really know
that much about them we have no idea how
these two know each other
why the pilot rook defected or why the
hell Squidward was in this movie dude
you gotta let that go
No what was that what was that in the
movie stop putting scenes with tentacles
in your movies they don't work it might
be a good thing not knowing their
stories though that's when you do it
almost makes us less interested in them
somehow I'm kind of angry with you I've
heard what I grew with you is that you
were my kind of father I thought a kind
of race tool that we had a kind of
connection Wow we went over everything I
feel like more attachment yeah I'm not
gonna miss you when you're dying
speaking of which that blast by the way
was a test by the death star done by
general critic and grand moff tarkin
wait a minute how do they do that if
Peter Cushing is dead oh no not that's
right digital talking target available
now from Hasbro for only 14.95 Lloyd
would prohibited oh god it's like Jeff
Bridges from Tron Legacy mixed with Jim
Carrey from A Christmas Carol well it's
actually not that bad
sometimes the CG is very impressive it
always looks like somebody's really
there but the uncanny valley distracts
from ever fully accepting it sometimes
he looks convincing but the rest of the
time you'd swear they put the fake lips
of John Lennon from fourth jump on there
make it so they have nothing left on
that planet no possessions no religion
it's easy if you try
dick dismissed oh good at least the
scene is over oh and don't forget we
have like five more meetings in the next
24 hours
ah that's the other thing he's in this
film a lot it kind of makes you wonder
why they didn't just replace him with
Darth Vader who's only given less than
10 minutes in the movie he's one of the
most famous villains who always wears a
mask why not use this guy as much as
possible well to be fair it might be
because James Earl Jones's voice is
sounding a little tired after doing it
all these years oh my god are they still
making these okay where's the script
how many lines do I have what licit oh
Christ I was in the send a lot longer
what am i literally just taking a bath
while I'm off-screen okay okay look here
general critic critic what the hell kind
of name is that it's like in one ear and
out the other forgotten I forgot I even
said it oh fuck it just don't have me
scream no and we'll be good I don't care
if he sounds old he starts fader we
deserve more of him remember when this
guy directed Aaron taylor-johnson also
starring Godzilla oh that Godzilla movie
they had almost no Godzilla right yeah
but to be fair that movie had such bland
main characters that just weren't that
interesting and you couldn't get sucked
into you see where I'm going with this
yeah well the side characters weren't
well enough our main leads are mostly
pretty flat it's almost like they were
given direction to not be awful but not
be interesting either how do you know
your father's not the enemy I saw his
message he's on our side he said so yes
yes in a totally passable yet
unexceptional way I am passionate about
this but not too passionate in case
we're all to die at the end right so the
people don't get too depressed so we can
still market this as a deep yet
enjoyable adventure oh did I know here
we have toys okay okay
[Music]
you
Jim's father is killed by the Empire as
once again it doesn't seem as
emotionally investing as it probably
should be Jim I put the weakness in the
Death Star so small that they'll never
notice it in fact it's so small that
every time they build a new one it'll
have the exact same weakness really they
never catch on they use a Jolly wrenches
for the edges and then exactly the
brightest stars in the solar system
okay I'm dead now upon finding out that
the rebels don't want to sneak in to get
the plans for the Death Star our team
decides to go it alone and get it
themselves everything's under control
situation normal had a slight weapons
malfunction but we're perfectly fine
here we're all fine here now thank you
how are you our name uh should think of
something hurry rogue what makes more
sense than just coming up with that out
of the blue conversation anyway we're
company so Road one goes to the Empire's
base to steal the plans the rebels
eventually end up joining them and you
know how Force awakens was friggin
awesome but the climax was kind of me
rogue one was kind of mad but the climax
was friggin awesome if you want oh the
truth we haven't got a great space
battle since Return of the Jedi we did
eventually get a good Star Wars film but
the space battles were still usually too
busy with too much clutter going on this
follows one ship at a time again making
it feel like you're there in fact a lot
of it really feels like you're in the
action because of the exciting even
realistic way it's shot but doesn't just
stop there it moves it to the next level
you know how in Return of the Jedi they
smash a Star Destroyer which by the way
never destroys any stars ironic because
they have a weapon that destroys planets
in fact doesn't that star in Star
Destroyer kind of mean like the same
anyway you remember how its smashed into
the Death Star in a giant blaze while in
this one a ship pushes in just the right
place crashes into another Star
Destroyer which crashes into the shield
blocking the planet and just before
another one shows up crashing into a
dozen other ships it's amazing this does
still raise the question though if beta
is in this movie why isn't he down there
on that beach kicking ass oh hello
sand oh right he ain't said it so coarse
rough and irritating and it gets
everywhere because posters like all over
the place how could you miss this yes
I'll have to go down there don't you
have like a million stormtroopers yeah
but I can actually hit something however
Darth Vader comes back my god does he
come back just when you think he
contributed nothing to this movie he
comes aboard one of the ships and is
like I have cold
to deliver the most awesome in the movie
no this is nothing this is literally
nothing I can do this with no hands
Jim my severus awesome Rick head making
people shorter check chicken I'm not
even looking at you I'm not even looking
at you that's how easy this is
I'm so cool look at this punk ass looks
like a rebel kool-aid oh that's right
bitches
I'm stuffing that with my head with my
god damn head but know what they say
what goes in must come out out my ass
okay here we go everybody I'm fucking
amazing what you gonna do what you're
gonna do shit's getting hot in here huh
oh okay yeah we're gonna Duke it out
we're gonna Duke it out we're tough guy
huh oh I'm so scared
dunk Vader's gonna die from your pussy
fist you're gonna see the galaxy goes
head right oh wait I forgot I can choke
a bitch
[Music]
dockside motherfuckers
so yep that was the greatest Darth Vader
scene and all movie history despite all
the film's flaws
it gave us two solid minutes of holy
shit nice
and speaking of flaws there's still a
few before we wrap up like how the
emotional highlight is supposed to be
the death of our two leads you're not
really gonna lose sleep over you won't
miss us but you didn't dislike us either
our job is complete
and because the Tarkin wasn't freaky
enough we also get a CGI Princess Leia
to top it all off Christ just tell me
they do it better than Tarkin sometimes
it looks better and sometimes it looks
worse it's kind of weird how long is she
on screen about 10 seconds how can there
be such a drastic change in only 10
seconds we have a new hope you need an
exorcist
thus the rebels head off with the plans
and the film comes to a close
and that was road one the most
above-average Star Wars prequel the film
is famously gone through rewrites and
reshoots and it clearly shows a lot of
the time it feels all over the place but
some of the places they go to have some
great atmosphere and action the biggest
problem is the characters aren't as
memorable or fondness some of the other
films meaning it doesn't feel as large
or epic there's certainly problems with
it but it's hard to say there aren't a
lot of cool seams that overshadow them
it's not funny
per se but it is cool it's definitely
more aggressive in like an actual war
and that often times makes the world
feel more real it never quite goes to
aggressive but it doesn't really take
any chances either there's no surprises
and you get exactly what you'd expect
but what I expected wasn't that bad so I
enjoy myself fine it's a perfectly OK
good they've got the crawler gets about
time
[Music]
you know it does raise a good question
what if we do get too many Star Wars
movies I mean before Star Wars was
gigantic weather was loved or hated but
what if it just becomes okay what if
it's not great not awful it's just
average what if it becomes like every
other franchise you know before the
prequels there were a lot of cool Star
Wars stories books video games comics
and a lot of them had a wide variety of
acceptance some were great some were
awful some were just okay so you see
critic Star Wars was a franchise before
it was a franchise I never thought of it
like that and yeah we'll always have the
original movies ish I guess that does
count for something
you know critic no matter what Star Wars
will always be special
[Music]
but will we ever get a Darth Vader scene
as cool as the one in this movie
look Darth Vader is one of the best
villains of all time they could do
anything with him who knows what's on
the horizon that is
[Music]
like what oh okay I felt like we were at
a good spot there it was a good spot
really I wasn't feeling that okay like
what like what like what uh they could
CG a cartoon face on Bea Arthur Wow
that'd be amazing
yeah okay we'll stop more okay I really
need him out I need it out yeah I could
fly to riches I'm Chris stuckman and I
can breathe in space for some reason
[Music]
dude that's it we're done there's
nothing more yeah that's the last review
of the year I don't know what else
you're expecting that's it we're done
I'll see you in January
wait a minute next month is January you
know what that means
dockside motherfuckers
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing action
against hunger this is an international
relief and development organization
committed to saving the lives of
malnourished children and families while
providing sustainable access to safe
water and long-term solutions donger
recognized as a world leader in the
fight against hunger they have pursued
its vision of a world without hunger for
nearly three decades combating hunger in
emergency situations of conflict natural
disaster and chronic food insecurity as
part of the action against hunger
international network with headquarters
in New York London Madrid Montreal and
Paris their field staff work in over 40
countries to carry out innovative
life-saving programs in nutrition food
security water and sanitation health and
advocacy their programs reach over four
million people a year both their site
and their YouTube channel show all the
people that they're helping and how you
can help them as well nobody deserves to
go to bed hungry and you can help a
child and adult anyone sleep well for
several nights so please click on the
link here these stories watch their
videos and find out how you can make a
huge difference
[Music]
you